hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game or rather should i say
games that come as a suggestion from
goran martic so thank you for that it's
uh
really an impressive one and i was first
very confused when he suggested this
game because when i tried to find it in
the database i found a similar game only
the well after some 20 moves were played
the game goes in a different direction
then i realized that there are actually
two games between these two gentlemen i
played in the same year 1860 in brazil
uh or maybe one was in 1859 the other
one was in 1860 but no one really knows
however both of them are incredible and
it seems that uh here
out of understand who you guys know very
well especially if you've been following
the morphe saga
he is uh well most of you if you've only
been following the morphe saga know him
as the final boss of the morphe saga but
he's actually
an incredible guy himself he is the the
man who created the original immortal
game after that you know every
spectacular game was deemed
the title immortal uh also he is the
creator of the evergreen game which you
guys have seen either by him playing it
or maybe in the uh game between uh
magnus carlsen and max deutsch so he's a
very well known uh gentleman and he's
playing against the german uh master
bertral tschule uh who is um well
sometimes referred to as the german paul
morphy by some people but that's uh
not really uh important for this game uh
so let's dive straight into it and uh
see uh why this is so impressive and why
i was so confused when i first
started preparing it so anderson has the
white pieces and he opens with uh e4 we
knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop to
c4 the italian game is on the board
bishop to c5 and you guys of course know
what comes next when anderson is uh
wielding the white pieces of course b4
the evans gambit is on the board the
strongest ever opening invented by man
uh bishop captures on b4 accepting the
gambit c3 and the bishop back to c5 now
there are a lot of possible retreats
with the bishop for those of you who
don't don't know i did make a video on
the evans gambit so if you guys are
interested i covered pretty much all of
the
bishops retreats not that one uh in the
video so it will be the first link in
the description below if you want to
check that out as well but here
of course both of these guys
know this very well so understand just
castles we have d6 and anderson strikes
in the center with d4 e cap press on d4
c captures on d4 and now bishop to b6 of
course not bishop to b4 trying to
prevent white from playing rook to e1
which seems like a good idea but then
just d5 and you're lost because now you
either give up the knight or the knight
moves and then queen a4 check picks up
the bishop so now the bishop has to go
to b6 even though anderson had one
opponent that actually played bishop to
b4 but okay here bishop to b6 we have d5
challenging the knight knights the a5
attacking the bishop and now uh well
another lesson of um how to not play
automatic moves bishop to b2 so here you
might think okay my opponent is
attacking my bishop i should either
defend or move it but anderson says nope
development comes first first bishop to
b2 and now black is the one that has to
react because if the knight captures on
c4 we're gonna grab the pawn on g7 and
then pick up the rook and f8 on h8 so
here knight to f6 blocking the bishop
and now only now we bring the bishop
back to d3 while defending our e for
pawn so bishop to g4 surely says all
right i i'm just going to nicely develop
my bishop and not allow your knights to
move and you really don't have all that
much here so anderson plays knight to c3
and here comes c6
uh sorry c6 challenging uh the center
here and this is a sort of a new move
but not really as like i said two of
them have played this position not once
but twice uh anderson plays knight to e2
he wants to shift the knight over to the
attack with um i would moves like
knight
to g3 uh and here you could consider
castling uh capturing an f3 but if
captures g captures on f3 white has a
very strong center there's uh not all
that much uh
black achieved here uh other than giving
up the bishop pair here white will play
king to h1 rook is coming to g1 white
will uh have immense pressure over the
king side here so instead schuler just
castles and now we have queen to d2 now
anderson is ready to bring the queen in
via the dark squares uh and this is
where things um get very very
interesting so here we have rook the c8
but this is uh the move that was played
in this game and we're also gonna cover
the other game where uh an improvement
was found to this move because this
didn't work out all that well for for mr
schuler uh so let's see what happens
here after rook the c8 anderson brings
the queen in queen to g5 now you can see
that something is bound to happen
on the g7 square uh but white says okay
for the moment you don't have any
threats bishop captures on f3 g captures
on f3 and c captures on d5 what
what are you even doing here uh mr
anderson so here king to h1 uh he wants
to play rook to g1 put even more
pressure on the pawn uh and here you
absolutely have to play knight to e8 and
add a defender to the g7 pawn but uh
shula says all right i can do this
anytime i'm just going to play knight to
c4 and attack one of the attackers of
the g7 pawn so first you have to react
to this and then i'm going to deal with
the g7 pawn but anderson just plays rook
the g1 now he threatens mate on g7 and
true says all right now i'm going to
play knights the e8 because you're kind
of really forcing me to so here knight
to e8 and not only am i defending g7 but
also i'm offering a queen trade uh the
problem for schuler is that anderson has
a forced checkmate in five here so feel
free to pause the video and win this
game for anderson while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
g7 pawn is not really defended all that
well and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is queen captures
and g7 and that's right anderson always
finds a way to sacrifice his queen
knight captures on g7 this is the only
move and now rook captures on g7 king
the h8 and now again anderson shows us
how to always attack uh with with
absolute precision the problem is yes
you are threatening a lot of very nasty
discoveries the problem is uh even if
you could deliver check without the the
bishop being captured still this f6 move
is uh uh
playable and then both the rook and the
queen will be guarding the f6 square so
how do you play this uh it's actually a
mating three from here there's only one
way to do it and that is rook the g8 we
do a double check
and as they say even the bravest king
flees in in the face of a double check
so now you have to capture the rook
there is no other move uh rook king
captures rook on g8 and now rook the g1
check and now you are checking the king
while also preventing him from going to
the dark squares and now there is only
one move for black that is queen to g5
and after this anderson just captures it
with the rook and this is now rook
captures on g5 checkmate so brilliant
brilliant game only 23 moves brought to
you by none other than the evans gambit
wielded by one of uh the greatest
players ever of the evan's gambit adolf
andersen but now
let's uh go to the game that i actually
wanted to show you and that is
after this queen the d2 move was played
here in this game uh rook the c8 was
played and you you've seen that it
didn't really work out all that great
for schuler so here he throws in an
improvement like i said i don't know uh
the time uh the difference between the
two games could be a year could be a
couple of months could be later in the
afternoon so it's not really specified
so here instead of rook to c8 we have
knight back to d7 and now okay his idea
is clear he's not allowing queen to g5
now his queen is guarding the g5 square
and he says all right this is a a great
improvement i'm uh looking uh forward to
the rest of the game very much uh
anderson now plays queen uh four saying
that okay i still have immense pressure
over the kings i look at my bishops my
knights are coming into the game the
queen is very nicely placed i am
attacking your bishop here and
well
if you've seen what happened in the
previous game and chula definitely has
he does not want to open up the g file
for the rook and this might explain uh
his uh uh
retreating the uh
the bishop here uh because you you do
want to capture here captures queen
captures then maybe bring the queen over
with queen to g5 so there are many ideas
here however uh last game didn't end all
that great for him so he goes back
bishop to h5 he wants to put the bishop
on g6 and then use it as a defender but
now knight g3 bishop the g6 and now the
move anderson is famous for rook 8 d1 if
you've seen anderson's evergreen game
then rook 8 d1 is uh a movie you know
all too well but if you haven't seen it
do check it out either by checking out
the original evergreen game or by
checking out the magnus versus max
deutsche game they are the exact same
game uh so here c captures on the five
black says you've got nothing here
that's uh that's a ridiculous move we
have e captus and d5 now opening up the
light square bishop but also black can
just capture this bishop if black wants
to but black wants more here knight to
c5 attacking the bishop on d3 and now
the bishop is attacked twice so what do
you do here uh anderson continues going
forward uh knight to f5 as the quote
says attack always attack
and now it's black the move the g7 pawn
is being threatened so how can black uh
go about this position well the only
possible way to play this and it's an
ugly one is to play f6 but still black's
position is already incredibly bad uh
here knight captures and d3 was played
and now again we've reached the position
from the thumbnail so you guys know
what's happening here uh here anderson
just played queen to h6 and he was in
this position on move 20 that uh
berthold truly resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
there is checkmate being threatened on
g7 the knight attacks g7 the bishop
attacks g7 and there is absolutely
nothing black can do here if you try
capturing the queen then just knight
captures on h6's checkmate as the dark
squares are covered by the bishop
uh and if you don't capture the queen
there's well really not all that much
you can do the only way to defend the
pawn is by something like queen f6
bishop d4
but those are just moves that you can
throw in and get checkmated a few moves
later so interestingly at this game
anderson finishes in 20 moves unlike the
previous one that we've seen that he
finished in 23 moves so even with this
incredible improvement instead of rook
to c8 surely playing knight to d7 which
is actually the strongest move
recommended by the engine and it gives
black the advantage anderson not only
wins the game again
he wins it with a queen sacrifice and it
took him three moves less than it did in
the original game so uh incredible guy
this adolf anderson just playing the
evan's gambit like that and whatever the
opponent throws at him you know the
strongest moves recommended by the
engine he still just mounts the attack
and you know
finishes off the game with a beautiful
queen sacrifice but this is just um uh
just proved that uh anderson was a
brilliant brilliant attacker definitely
ahead of his time and also that the
maybe the quality and technique of
defense back in 1860 was not uh
up to today's standards but uh that that
of course i'm very happy that it's like
that because if it wasn't if everyone
was defending perfectly like they do
today most of the times then we would
not have all of these amazing games with
such amazing sacrifices uh so yeah
that's the game or rather the games i
hope you guys enjoyed them both uh thank
you to uh goran martis for recommending
such a such a beauty
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to mehmet from ftm uh and nbsp
there was a lot more written here but i
couldn't fit all of it in uh and i would
like to thank dr alomot wesley uh
luffborough andrei schrader and uh andra
lazaroy for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh andra actually contributed to meadow
as uh today is uh actually meadows um a
15th birthday so uh he's uh he's a very
old dude i always joke around that he's
uh ancient that no one knows how old he
is but today is actually his 15th
birthday he's uh currently sleeping
meadow
uh if you want to say something to the
to the good people uh of the channel not
now's your opportunity
uh
there you go nope
all right so
at least he he he woke up so you can see
his face uh but yeah we had a we had a
long walk today he had uh he had a very
nice piece of cake it was a it was a
very healthy cake as he is pretty old so
he has to watch out what he eats uh but
he he spent the day well but most of the
time he is napping uh so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it um brilliant
brilliant stuff from adolf andersen as
usual
uh as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon by continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and always play the evidence
gambit do check out the tutorial in the
description below see you soon